[Musique]
après 7 mois derrière les barreaux c'est
enfin le grand jour pour Karim un
véritable comité d'accueil s'est réuni
sa soeur et des amis sont venus pour
l'accompagner dans ses premiers pas
d'homes libres
[Applaudissements]
après un mois un an 20 ans derrière les
barreaux un jour il sorte ils sont enfin
libres
de reconstruire des liens avec leur
famille libre de travailler libre de se
loger libre de vivre tout simplement
mais avec 6 euros en poche pas d'emploi
et la prison derrière soi la liberté
n'est pas indolore si chaque année 85000
détenus franchissent les portes de la
prison seul 30% arrive à s'en sortir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas certain d'être inséré
c'est tous les jours
un combat pour
pour pas y retourner quoi parce que j'ai
pas des siècles à vivre j'ai
passé bref 26 ans là-bas et puis
peut-être la réinsertion c'est de la
lâcher
j'ai quand même la rage quoi
26 ans il tente de sécurité dont 12 ans
pour une heure qui n'a jamais été réparé
Roger que c'est condamné en 1972 à 15
ans de réclusion criminelle
accusé d'avoir agressé un pompiste avec
une arme pour un butin de 800 francs il
ne cessera de clamer son innocence
de sa cellule rogic nobelpis dénonce
l'inhumanité du système carcéral
il écrira deux livres sur les quartiers
de haute sécurité et les humiliations
faites au détenu
autour du dollar militant écrivain
intellectuel et artiste se mobilisent
depuis le temps qu'on a essayé de
charger Roger que noblesse qu'on a
essayé de l'écraser c'est bien qui est
qu'à un moment donné ça s'arrête parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit de s'acharner sur
un homme comme ça
celui qu'on appelle clope entre dans la
légende et devient le révolté des
prisons françaises
glacier par le président François
Mitterrand il sort de prison en
[Musique]
19817 ans je sais pas si vous rendez
compte que c'est 17 ans je vais écouter
je sors avec beaucoup d'incertitudes et
beaucoup d'affolement est-ce que je vais
retrouver la faculté de vie je n'ai plus
la faculté de vivre vous devriez avoir
devant vous quelqu'un qui rigole je
rigole pas
j'ai envie de pleurer je trouve que
c'est tellement horrible la prison c'est
une invention à nacronique j'ai
l'invention d'un autre âge d'abord je
suis sorti avec une haine une urgence
phénoménale quoi
j'ai passé 12 ans de la vie en prison
donc pour rien elle a la rage mais on
peut imaginer
j'avais plein d'intellectuels qui me
soutenaient etc et je mentais à tout le
monde à tout le monde je devenais le bon
détenu exemplaire dans sa combativité
qui écrit des livres etc etc alors que
je n'avais qu'une envie c'était de les
tuer le Dieu ceux qui m'avait enfermé
quoi les matons qui m'avaient milliers
le mal qu'on m'a fait en prison je me
disais je vais venger et puis finalement
je me suis pas vengé j'ai frappé au
portefeuille
et très vite après sa libération le
symbole se fissure
braquage arrestation rebracage club des
soins clope replonge retour à la case
prison
[Musique]
enfin libre Roger knubble peace et cette
fois c'est pour de vrai
août 1990 clope sort de prison il aura
passé en tout plus de 26 ans derrière
les barreaux
marquée par ces années d'incarcération
club va devoir réapprendre à vivre
normalement
à vivre hors les murs
ça m'arrive encore 19 ans après de faire
un cauchemar je suis en état de
souffrance carcérale
enfin un moment il reste l'oeil et
l'oreille tout le reste du corps est
mort quoi de votre corps vous tournez en
rond vous êtes dans l'attente vous êtes
dans l'oubli
soupe du pain et les journées vides mais
vides vides
et le vide je me demande si c'est pas
pire que la mort
on peut vivre après la prison
moi je me pose toujours cette question
tous les jours je pense que je suis là
que je suis content d'être avec ma femme
et ma fille mais tous les jours je pense
que je vais en moi c'est un peu comme le
Marchand de Venise quoi j'ai une partie
de ma chair qu'on m'a appris quoi disons
de ma vie et c'est
pratiquement présent tous les jours
[Musique]
un détenu condamné à plus de 50 prisons
France la politique pénale est de plus
en plus sévère ces 10 dernières années
le nombre de ses prisonniers à doubler
et la durée des peines avec enfermé
infantiliser maintenu hors du monde un
jour il sorte et son livrés à eux-mêmes
après avoir subi la prison ils doivent
affronter la liberté que de récidive
chez les longs Pen mais de profonde
traumatismes
c'est éliminer proprement sournois
soit
en poussant la personne en suicide
ou soit par l'isolement en créant de la
pathologie c'est à dire le père de
naissance perdre de l'orientation
toutes les aspérités à exister sont
devenus des
des longues peines comme ça sont des
habitués à gérer leur propre vie donc on
voit des gens qui effectivement
et leur femme leur racontent très bien
s'arrête devant la porte et attendre
qu'on leur ouvre oublions que c'est eux
qui peuvent clancher la porte ou alors
certains qui ne ferment plus jamais la
porte des toilettes chez eux c'est
impossible parce que parce qu'ils
peuvent pas fermer d'abord ils ont plus
l'habitude et puis ensuite fermer des
portes etc c'est très difficile revivre
avec un conjoint trop trop proche et
l'on peine sont en cellule seule mais
ils ont l'habitude à 5h c'est fermé
jusqu'au lendemain matin 7h donc là
souvent c'est c'est très difficile de
repartager le quotidien absolument bien
sûr le problème de la sexualité est
énorme lorsque on a plus l'habitude
d'être touché de d'avoir un rapport de
tendresse d'avoir un rapport physique il
faut il faut réapprendre à vivre avec
son propre corps or
l'incarcération c'est d'abord
l'incarcération un corps et
physiologiquement ça se ressent les
femmes ont des troubles des règles quand
elles sont quand elles sont
incarcérées tout le système
hormonal ne fonctionne plus la même
manière très souvent il y a des
problèmes de vue je vous disais on a
commode pas loin et donc on a une vue
tunnelaire certaines personnes ne voient
plus correctement donc on voit que c'est
le corps lui-même qui au cours des
longues peines s'abîment c'est pour les
longues peines le plus durer
d'apprivoiser la liberté pour les
courtes peines c'est de ne pas replonger
le taux de récidive est deux fois plus
élevé pour les auteurs de délit que pour
les auteurs de crime
Fleury-Mérogis quartier courtepaigne ici
les détenus sont condamnés à des peines
de moins d'un an
et votre scénario
[Musique]
à l'âge de 21 ans Karim n'en est pas à
sa première incarcération
il purge sa deuxième peine de prison
7 mois ferme pour un délit routier
la prison comment ça se fait tout parce
que
on est dans un milieu qu'on est jeune
je sais pas comment dire on est dans
on sait qu'on va aller presque
il suit d'un milieu modeste un parcours
scolaire chaotique sans emploi
pour Karim la prison résonne comme une
fatalité
pour briser cette spirale de la prison à
répétition Karim participe avec 24
autres détenus tous volontaires à un
programme expérimental de lutte contre
la récidive le but préparer l'insertion
professionnelle avant même la sortie
pour cette opération l'administration
pénitentiaire travaille main dans la
main avec le Gepsa une fille idéale du
groupe Suez qui gère des prisons en
France
Lassina Hadj et les accompagne dans un
projet professionnel elle a deux mois de
stage pour leur apprendre à écrire une
lettre de motivation rédiger un CV ou
encore simuler un entretien d'embauche
citez-moi vos défauts vos qualités par
les mois de vous
en fait moi je suis fair-play je suis
loyal net respectueux ensuite je suis
ponctuel je suis
méticuleux je suis
attentifs alors se vendre à un employeur
potentiel peut-être un exercice
difficile
Karine va commencer donc on va voir si
l'opérationnel donc vous écoutez bien et
ensuite vous donnerez votre avis ok si
vous avez des remarques ou autres donc
on pourra échanger là-dessus après
l'entretien ok je suis l'employeur donc
Karim arrive de là-bas donc on observe
bien sa façon de marcher son
comportement sa gestuelle
bonjour bonjour monsieur et vous ça va
je vous en prie installez-vous
[Musique]
donc monsieur alors vous postulez pour
un poste de vendeur très bien c'est un
métier qui me correspond je trouve parce
que du relationnel j'aime bien parler
avec les gens
j'aime bien négocier les prix j'aime
bien communiquer j'ai bien la présence
humaine en fait donc
je préfère alors expliquez-moi vous vous
voyez comment dans 10 ans
donc ça c'est le volet personnel après
cette semaine de stage Karim arrive
enfin à parler de lui c'est pas mal hein
qui arrive au début du stage et Karim
aujourd'hui c'est pas le même il a un
discours structuré il a une bonne
sémantique de son projet il est posé
souriant il a il a une il est plaisant
comme comme personnage et c'est ça son
plus n'oubliez pas que vous avez élaboré
un projet professionnel
c'est ça le support c'est important
parler de projet professionnel bilan de
compétences un point aussi important
l'ambition c'est important de montrer
que qu'on a la niaque qu'on est motivé
qu'on se projette dans 5 ans dans 10 ans
c'est un élément positif ça prouve que
vous ne restez pas bloqué sur votre
incarcération mais que vous voyez
au-delà le passage par la case prison
n'est pas une ligne facile à effacer
d'un CV
60% des détenus quittent la prison sans
emploi
et sans réel espoir de réinsertion à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui sans emploi on
n'existe pas c'est quand même c'est une
dignité de d'avoir un emploi à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui c'est c'est sa place
garantie dans la société
sans emploi on est en marge donc le but
c'est de leur redonner une identité une
identité dans la société
[Musique]
j'arrive à fleurir je t'ai perdu parce
qu'il faut que je me refasse une
nouvelle équipe pour que je me remette
bien quoi
arrivant il me propose un programme une
fois une formation avec la télé gratuite
et avec des totaux des sports et tout
avec des RPS
avec des remises
à la base et après j'ai vu qu'il y avait
même pas c'était quoi la base de
programme bon juste du programme tout
donc problème je galère j'ai rien à
faire j'ai pas par exemple
un peu plus tranquille que les gens
j'ai gratté j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
dame
j'ai vu que j'avais quelque chose à
gratter avec elle pour le travail et
l'emploi je me dis que je vais gratter
un truc pour dehors moi
après voilà je suis arrivé là
pour les participants au stage le taux
de récidive a chuter d'un tiers mais
cette initiative ne concerne qu'une
toute petite partie de la population
carcérale sur 3900 détenus à
Fleury-Mérogis seulement 120 ont
participé à ce programme
l'administration pénitentiaire a pour
mission
la surveillance et la réinsertion mais
le déséquilibre est flagrant c'est
évidemment d'abord la surveillance et
d'abord le ce côté punition le côté
punition ça devrait être que la
privation de liberté et on sait bien que
c'est bien au-delà quant à la
réinsertion c'est une toute petite
partie c'est-à-dire que de temps en
temps il y a une action qui fait qu'on
va montrer un petit groupe de détenus
qu'on va aider à faire je sais pas quoi
le Tour de France à vélo une course à la
RAM il y a toujours deux trois choses
comme ça il y a des gens qui s'y donnent
beaucoup et c'est très bien qu'il le
fasse des encadrants des surveillants
des directeurs de prison qui le fassent
mais c'est quand même très souvent la
cerise sur le gâteau
[Musique]
centre ville de Nîmes le cabinet de
Maître la planche ce matin il reçoit un
jeune sous le choc d'une arrestation
plutôt musclée pour tapage nocturne
et les flics sont arrivés vous embarquez
un témoin qui nous aurait vu avec les
mêmes habits et même discrétifs
surtout la nuit
dès le début de la garde à vue est-ce
qu'ils vous ont notifié vos droits
qui ont rien se reprocher et qui se
retrouvent au news parce que justement
il néglige ce genre de précaution
il y en a tous les jours
mais Christian la planche n'est pas un
avocat comme les autres à 18 ans il
était en prison Christian Laplanche ou
l'histoire d'une réinsertion hors du
commun
[Musique]
c'est à 18 ans qu'il entame une courte
carrière de braqueurs en moins d'un an
une douzaine de hold-up condamnée à 50
prisons il passera 18 mois derrière les
barreaux
reconstitution du braquage du bureau de
poste
il y avait fouillir après-midi sur la
place de Barbentane curieux gendarmes
chien policier
c'est marrant qui précise ça des chiens
policiers si jamais
la circulation elle-même était détournée
c'était le jour de la reconstitution du
hold-up du bureau de poste encore
présent dans toutes les mémoires le 21
avril 82 deux hommes pénétrées dans
l'agence postale pour y commettre une
attaque amer
voilà
pendant son incarcération Christian
Laplanche change le cours de sa vie il
fasse son bac et commence des études de
droit
6 ans après sa sortie de prison il
devient maître de conférence à
l'Université de Cayenne
20 ans plus tard il prête serment comme
avocat tu étais marrante parce que c'est
quand j'ai prêté serment à Paris dès
lors Libération a fait un papier et
alors je savais pas que c'était le
c'était un papier avec il y avait tapis
là sur la première page retour gagnant
pour tapis et en fait ça me concernait
puisque c'était pour moi aussi un retour
gagnant
vous voyez ce que je veux dire parce que
j'avais
prêté serment à Paris sans retour
gagnant il le doit une robe la robe de
son juge d'instruction celui qui l'a
fait incarcéré mais aussi celui qui lui
a donné le goût du droit chaque fois que
je rentrais dans ce bureau de ce jus
d'instruction
il y avait un porte-manteau enfin un bec
de perroquet
sur lequel sur lequel était pendu sa
robe chaque fois que j'allais à
l'instruction et que je rentrais que je
regardais cette robe
mais je la regardais forcément parce que
c'est la robe qu'on porte quand on est
jambes de justice
alors je me disais tiens c'est une robe
comme ça qu'un jour je porterai très
certainement
ce que je savais pas au moment où je
regardais cette robe
ce que je savais pas c'est que j'allais
réellement la portée celle que je
regardais
vous inquiétez pas entendu
puisque ce juge d'instruction
a quitté ses fonctions de magistrats il
est devenu moine Dominique
qui porte une autre robe aujourd'hui
elle est blanche d'ailleurs robe
dominicaine sont blanche
et en fait sa robe de juge il me l'a
offert voilà
[Musique]
systématiquement qu'à chaque fois que je
mets cette robe et bien à chaque fois je
me dis qu'elle pèse lourd quoi
je passais trois fois aux assises quand
même j'étais jugé en correctionnel enfin
bon
j'ai été moi-même à la place de ces
personnes que je défends je sais ce que
c'est que de rentrer une tribu dans un
tribunal et puis
quand vous êtes vous-même
jugé parce que je l'ai été
jugé il a été de nouveau et cette fois
par ses pères les avocats du barreau de
Nîmes
ils avocats ni moi ne voulaient pas que
je sois avocat parce que
parce que
il ne pouvait pas accepter l'idée selon
laquelle
un avocat puisse un jour avoir fait de
la prison c'était pour certains c'est
insupportable
interdit d'exercer par le Conseil de
l'Ordre des avocats ni moi Christian
Laplanche obtient finalement gain de
cause en juillet 2008 après 5 longues
années de combat contre les préjugés
parler avec quelqu'un il s'est rien de
vous vous trouvez sympa tout ça ou pas
sympa enfin peu importe quelqu'un comme
n'importe qui
et puis un moment donné pour une raison
pour une autre cette personne elle sait
que vous avez fait de la prison c'est
incroyable il se passe quelque chose
dans sa tête elle vous voit pas la même
façon vous êtes quelqu'un d'autre d'un
coup vous êtes quelqu'un d'autre voilà
très bizarre comme truc
c'est bon on est toujours sur ce mode le
biais le mal etc si vous avez fait la
prison on a fait quelque chose de mal
donc vous représentez le mal vous êtes
mauvais quoi alors le temps n'y fait
rien je le vois encore aujourd'hui
tandis je peux faire un an 50 disant 20
ans 50 ans j'ai fait un jour de la
prison donc un truc qui va pas quoi
de fabrication
vous êtes
et là on se met le méfiance voilà qui
s'installe c'est une méfiance
instinctive qui s'installe chez celui
qui voit dans l'autre quelqu'un qui a
fait de la prison
la récidive je dirais est une suite
normale
de la prison
le contraire est une aberration qu'une
récit ne veut pas pour moi c'est un
mystère
donc vous êtes un mystère non je suis
l'arme qui cache la forêt sur certaines
vous êtes un exemple de réinsertion
oulala non je suis un contre-exemple
faut pas voir les choses comme ça moi je
suis là c'est pas normal ce qui s'est
passé
ok du 20e arrondissement de Paris le
soleil un des seuls centres en France
qui héberge les femmes à leur sortie de
prison elle ne représente que 4% de la
population carcérale
ma chérie bravo bravo
adjira une petite fille de 1 an à 37 ans
elle vient de purger une peine de 7 mois
et demi de prison
depuis sa sortie de Fleury-Mérogis il y
a trois mois
agira au cube avec Inès une des 12
chambres du centre d'hébergement
une chance pour la jeune femme qui en
sortant de prison n'avait pas de
logement pas de famille pour l'aider et
seulement 550 euros par mois
d'allocation par an isolé
[Musique]
principal c'est qu'on soit à l'abri
le souci c'est que voilà tout à
l'extérieur donc si je veux me laver les
mains
je vous la porte je laisse ma fille bien
sûr
je traverse le couloir
et je rouvre la porte
voilà c'est parce que les mamans ont une
salle de bain il y a un WC individuel
donc là d'un congélateur à un tiroir
sinon ils nous ont fait des placards
c'est fermé à clé aussi en fait ce qui
me
bloque c'est ouvrir fermer ouvrir fermer
parce que moi je m'étais juré j'ai dit
quand je sors je fermerai plus les
portes
tu finis
ainsi que quand tu sors du modèle prison
ces petits trucs là te rappellent la
prison
tu vois ce que je veux dire tu veux ou
tu veux pas ça te rappelle à présent
ouvre ferme ouvre ferme c'est la
détention tu viens avec maman
2 et 3
au soleil encadré
au centre un assistant social six
éducateurs seraient pour aider ces
femmes fragilisé par des vies chaotiques
et brisés par les années d'incarcération
bon vous savez pourquoi on se voit
aujourd'hui faire le point donc moi
comme je vous ai dit les bêtises ça a
été très tard moi j'ai eu ma vie j'ai eu
ma stabilité j'ai eu mon appartement
j'ai eu mon travail j'ai tout je suis
pas quelqu'un qui est sorti de chez Papa
et Maman et qui a été dans la rue non
oui donc ça a 37 ans que j'ai fait de la
prison c'est pas à 25 donc c'est pas du
tout la même chose
moi je veux récupérer ma vie de avant
avant les bêtises ma stabilité mon
appartement mon enfant qui va à l'école
mon petit boulot je vais je viens
j'emmène ma fille je reviens je fais à
manger je coupe tout le monde
donc je veux essayer d'avancer voilà
certaines connaissent pas le passage ne
connaissent pas l'euro donc n'ont pas
connu passager certaines n'ont jamais ne
connaissent pas Paris certaines n'ont
jamais travaillé ne savent pas ce que
c'est qu'un invités ne savent pas ce que
c'est qu'un employeur ne sont pas au
cours ne savent pas ce que c'est qu'un
contrat de travail souvent quand on
rencontre quelqu'un pour la fois dans la
vie on dit qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la
vie mais alors dites que vous sortez de
prison et que vous faites rien alors là
ça se voit pas du tout enfin je veux
dire ça va pas plaire
au soleil parmi la dizaine d'anciennes
détenus Algérie la seule à vivre avec
son enfant 24 heures sur 24
[Musique]
le plus dur c'était la sortie pourquoi
parce que j'étais incarcéré et
vu qu'on était déjà
ce qui est le plus dur en fin de compte
c'est quand on a les portes ouvertes les
clés parce que là on peut ouvrir notre
collier nous même que en prison
n'ouvrait pas notre courrier c'est la
détention qu'il l'ouvrait pour nous quoi
donc ici il y a plus de comment dire
on est plus libre quoi
et c'est ça qui vous fait peur
ouais au départ ouais parce que je
pouvais pas mettre un pied dans un
magasin quoi
vous aviez peur de quoi exactement de
regarder des gens
tu avais l'impression que quoi que tout
le monde savait et après je me suis dit
que j'affronte les gens des extérieurs
quoi
puis on n'a pas tous vécu la même
incarcération aussi il y en a qu'on fait
moins de prison que d'autres en ont fait
le plus donc on a pas tous
l'extérieur tu en as le son seul par
exemple Nathalie elle est pas de Paris
déjà à la base donc et en plus tu sors
de prison
la personne Nathalie en dehors du
soulier voilà elle est elle était comme
moi elle est comme une âme perdue c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est retrouvé c'est
simple parce qu'on n'aurait pas un point
commun ce serait pas retrouvé le point
commun c'est que ici on sentait
énormément seul
vous auriez où si vous n'étiez pas au
soleil
moi
depuis la sortie ou au jour
d'aujourd'hui depuis la sortie
sincèrement je sais pas je ne sais pas
parce qu'après tu peux pas savoir
je veux dire l'énergie ou la force que
tu peux déployer pour te sortir de ta
mère donc
je sais pas moi
s'il y aurait pas eu le soleil
[Musique]
sont marqués offert rouge taularde alors
vivre dans un centre avec des règles
leur rappel sans cesse l'enfermement des
horaires strictes l'obligation
d'entretenir les parties communes et les
hommes interdit de visite
[Musique]
une contrainte ingérable pour agira qui
ne peut accueillir le père de sa fille
Laurent il vient de sortir de prison
et lui non plus n'a pas d'emploi il vit
dans un hôtel social pour les 100
domicile fixe à l'autre bout de Paris
donc encore moins
le premier jour de sortie dans la rue
tous les trois
temps même les gestes de la petite les
retrouvailles
pour l'instant oui et non je peux dire
parce que
oui pour les retrouvailles et pour le
reste ça va
[Musique]
le couple passé journée à régler
d'innombrables formalités
administratives
[Musique]
allez allez je veux les comptes là je
vais contrôler là est-ce que tu as bien
fait ce qu'il fallait que tu fasses une
étape longue et complexe indispensable
pour retrouver une vie normale un
appartement un emploi et une crèche pour
Inès
il va falloir transférer ton dossier
quand tu sors tu changes d'adresse donc
il faut remettre à jour ta sécu ton RMI
tout à couverture sociale tout en
système où tout remettre pour faire le
tour leur donner les papiers donc papier
de sortie domiciliation ton nouvel
adresse postale pour que les droits
soient réouverts et prouver que tu te
réinsère dans la société c'est ça pour
eux c'est que tu déclares à toutes les
différents services que tu es dehors et
où tu te trouves et si tu as des droits
contre les œuvres ou pas
on va jamais rien lâcher un poupoune
bonjour bonjour
cet après-midi ils ont rendez-vous à
horizon un centre d'accueil et de soins
pour parents souffrant d'addiction
bonjour
[Musique]
je suis Brigitte d'aller je suis
responsable du pôle hébergement et donc
j'ai appris par mes collègues vous aviez
fait une demande de séjour en
appartement thérapeutique à Paris le
centre dispose de 11 appartements
thérapeutiques des lieux de soins ou
psychologues assistantes sociales et
éducateurs veille sur les locataires
c'est le dernier espoir du couple pour
vivre ensemble
nous on en a besoin on appelle au
secours on demande on est vraiment en
danger on le sent donc on prévient donc
voilà
nous notre
l'un de nos problèmes c'est pour ça
qu'on est suivi à horizon c'est pour ce
problème de consommation donc on est
dans la piscine
vu le temps de détention moi j'ai été à
Pierre Nicole auparavant donc quand même
il y a un an d'abstinence donc si une
situation comme ça perdure
c'est dangereux pour des gens comme nous
parce que vous savez que le produit
c'est quand même un petit diable qui est
là et qui attend que vous baissiez votre
garde et ça vous retombe dessus et la
descente aux enfers elle est dix fois
plus rapide que si comme si que c'était
la première fois où vous utilisez ce
produit vous vous sentiez en sécurité
par rapport à ça en prison
en sécurité non parce que pour moi le
vrai combat il se passe à l'extérieur là
c'est c'est une obligation j'avais pas
le choix donc c'est pour ça que là le
travail on continue à le faire mais à
l'extérieur c'est là que les vraies
choses se passent et pour pouvoir donner
les moyens de continuer dans cette
lancée il nous faut ce petit cocon où on
sait qu'on est en déjà être en sécurité
par rapport à la rue parce que c'est
dans la rue qu'on trouve ce produit
c'est quand même avoir un chez soi mais
en même temps vous allez forcément être
traversé par des moments d'outintance ou
par peut-être même des désaccords entre
vous deux concernant l'éducation de
votre enfant ou les choix à faire dans
tel ou telle situation ou comment gérer
la vie au quotidien quand on a un enfant
parce que finalement cette vie au
quotidien vous l'avez vécu ensemble tous
les deux mais quand même avec un
troisième personnage important qu'elle a
avec Inès tous les trois sans produits
ça c'est pas encore
réalisé ça non donc c'est cet
apprentissage là que vous allez pouvoir
faire cette expérimentation là on en est
au balbutiements
[Applaudissements]
ça s'est bien passé
il faut attendre il faut attendre que
ça apporte ses fruits
elle va payer on verra bien vous êtes
plutôt optimiste ou négatif
je pense c'est mieux placé pour pour
comprendre
la situation est-ce qu'on est en train
de vivre
ils sont ils sont vraiment spécialisés
dans la chose voilà ils savent ce que
c'est que souffrir la galère la rue en
tout cas il ne peut-être pas le savoir
mais en tout cas peut-être qu'il le
comprennent mieux que d'autres voilà
c'est la clé pour la situation à trois
c'est la seule c'est le seul passage
qu'on a trouvé pour l'instant
[Musique]
lorsqu'ils vont être dans la prison ils
vont être tenus par les murs et il y a
pas cette angoisse de vivre comme ça
parce qu'on leur dit tout
voilà c'est l'heure du repas vous ils
sont dépendants mais dépendants des murs
de la prison et dépendant du système de
la prison donc ils sont infantilisés et
ça leur va d'une certaine manière ça
leur va c'est qu'ils arrivent à survivre
assez bien là-dedans mais lorsqu'ils
vont être dehors là il va falloir à
nouveau marcher tout seul et devenir un
adulte autonome et là c'est aussitôt
l'angoisse
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Karim le jeune
multirécidiviste de Fleury-Mérogis a
obtenu une permission de sortie
exceptionnelle
à Cina son tuteur de projet lui a
décroché un entretien pour une formation
Karim a encore du mal à y croire je me
dis quand je sors comment ça se perd il
veut est-ce que tu me dis est-ce qu'ils
vont ça va me refaire comme à chaque
fois la carotte du siècle est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux
pour faire semblant mais en fait quand
on sort il y a rien
[Musique]
donc détenues 24 heures sur 24 sans axe
de liberté ils doivent demander la
permission pour tout donc ils sont très
infantilisés du jour au lendemain on les
balance comme ça dehors merci au revoir
et on leur dit de s'adapter à la liberté
c'est c'est violent
c'est justement pour éviter une sortie
trop brutale que ce programme existe
Karim a rendez-vous dans un lycée
professionnel de Seine-Saint-Denis avec
le responsable de l'enseignement
continue monsieur Crosnier
donc Régis je vous présente Karine c'est
le candidat dont je vous ai parlé si
Karim réussit cet entretien il pourra
décrocher une formation de vendeur de 5
mois un passeport pour sa réinsertion et
il va vous exprimer ses motivations
comme un grand alors
vous êtes allés à l'école donc vous êtes
allé jusqu'à quel niveau
donc ça vous intéressait la plomberie
mais vous n'avez pas obtenu votre cap
pourquoi
j'espère
la juge c'est pas une intensité c'est un
centre éducatif fermé
en fait il a eu un parcours complètement
décousu lié à aux incarcérations à
répétition
d'accord bon qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire alors
vous voulez de vendeur
en quoi
c'est dans le domaine que je pense
le mieux
excusez-moi
[Musique]
sa carrure sa carrure
stabiliser pour mettre en confiance je
vous en prie au revoir
excusez-moi
bon
donc maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous venez rechercher dans
cette formation en plus des personnes
qui peuvent m'aider à en prendre mieux
le métier de vendeur acquérir plus
d'expérience
comme ça quand j'arrive directement
en milieu professionnel
je mets
un niveau un peu plus élevé
je pense que j'ai mérite encore cette
expérience vous avez encore besoin
d'expérience sachez que le plus dur pour
n'importe quel jeune ça soit vous un
autre c'est de tenir on se fixe un
objectif on ne le lâche pas vous ne
pourrez véritablement dire que vous avez
réussi et donc réussi vous ne pourrez
véritablement vous insérer que si vous
donnez les moyens donc si vous avez une
présence si vous avez une volonté mais
aujourd'hui vous me le dites il faudra
aussi que vous me le disiez à la fin et
à ce moment là vous verrez que vous
insérez
merci
[Musique]
pas
facilement et toujours montrer technique
de réparer dans un vif du sujet puis là
j'ai pas eu le temps de parler bien
s'arrêter de parler c'est ça aussi un
dialogue
non non parce que trop parler c'est
c'est mauvais en même temps on doit
laisser la parole au recruteur il a
quand même une position supérieure face
à vous c'est vous qui êtes en demande à
vous de l'écouter et s'il vous coupe la
parole vous n'avez pas répliqué et je
trouve que c'est bien parce que ça ça
prouve qu'on a de la Discipline la
Discipline de la communication c'est
savoir se taire au moment opportun
pizza plomberie
et j'ai eu que des petits boulots moi
j'ai pas eu de assortiment un vrai
projet professionnel à suivre et avec
madame je suis mon projet professionnel
le soir de l'entretien retour en cellule
pour Karine encore un mois à tenir avant
sa sortie définitive
[Musique]
7h du matin
l'abri des familles devant la prison de
Fleury-Mérogis
[Musique]
près 7 mois derrière les barreaux c'est
enfin le grand jour pour Karim un
véritable comité d'accueil s'est réuni
sa soeur et des amis sont venus pour
l'accompagner dans ses premiers pas
d'ombre
il va le grec tu es survivalent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'on dit
le grand sud de la liberté
le premier des premiers jours c'est
cette euphorie c'est
l'impression que
on va renaître quoi et puis très vite on
est déçu par la liberté
il y a pas en prison on imagine un genre
humain différent on imagine des
rencontres on imagine des gens qui ont
pas parlé on imagine des gens
qui peuvent se battre des gens embrasés
et puis on s'aperçoit que
on a été libéré pour être au milieu je
dirais des esclaves masqués des escales
Nîmes ou des moutons de Panurge
[Musique]
de la mort avec de l'argent trade faut
les nourrir ta famille mais tes parents
la vérité du bitume la cité mon frère
c'est la merde c'est la merde voilà
c'est la merde
que j'ai un mois un moment dans la
journée je peux dans la cité comme avant
et tout faut que
tout ça
les copains de retrouver le quartier on
a honte on a ce weekend
il y a pas de fierté non plus
on va se on va se refaire un petit à
petit il y a quelqu'un qui mousse
sinon les autres bonjour au revoir sans
plus
les mecs qui les mecs qui traînent avec
eux mon frère
tu fais six sept mois comme ça en prison
il t'oublie
pas c'est pas grave c'est rien
il y a pas de potes dès que tu as 20 ans
21 ans ça y est c'est fini les poissons
12 ans que les potes tu traînes avec eux
maintenant
attends tu tournes
là il était grand
pour se reconstruire se poser Karim peut
compter sur le soutien d'une famille
unie
[Rires]
son frère aîné Jamel sa soeur son petit
neveu et ses parents sont tous là pour
l'accueillir
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu travailles pas obligé de bêtises avec
les copains avec les
la nuit
même j'ai resté sans travail j'ai occupé
lui jusqu'à il travaille entre la maison
d'accord je partir à un homme à la
maison j'ai fermé c'est obligé ça mais
c'est pas une sortie toute la nuit toute
la journée
il va travailler entre la maison je sais
qu'il va pas recommencer je sais qu'il
est motivé pour travailler et faire des
choses de projets je sais que je sais
qu'il a compris
l'espoir de trouver un emploi tient
carré mort de l'eau mais si le programme
ne tient pas sa promesse de réinsertion
car il n'est pas à l'abri de revenir à
sa vie d'avant à l'argent facile et aux
petits délits
[Musique]
ce matin à Gira quitte le soleil et
Nathalie son ami
[Musique]
c'est quelques arrondissements qui nous
séparent et l'emménage dans un
appartement thérapeutique avec Laurent
et la petite Inès un répit pour le
couple peut être enfin l'espoir de
retrouver une vie normale
c'est ta fille c'est clair elle est née
innocente elle restera innocente je
l'espère
[Musique]
pour Karim aussi un peu de répit
retour sur les bancs de l'école vous
aurez toujours le montant du salaire
brut il a 4 mois pour apprendre les
techniques de vente avant de trouver un
emploi son dernier espoir pour ne pas
replonger
directement
dans le domaine que j'aime bien et voilà
c'est plutôt une bonne chose vous êtes
contents
mais il a fallu que j'aille en prison
pour trouver ça
[Musique]
l'espoir d'un emploi pour Karim
un logement pour Adja mais un avenir
toujours un certain
[Musique]
60% des anciens détenus ont de nouveau à
faire avec la justice
[Musique]